AJ starts off this hour in the
Cincinnati hi AJ how are you I'm doing
great Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up um so my wife and I
are coordinating our very first ftu
class uh-huh and we have a member who's
the financial advisor for a living and
after going through the dumping debt
lesson he's convinced that there is
still good debt and bad debt and that he
can be responsible with a credit card
and so last night after the dumping debt
lesson we had a pretty good conversation
about renting versus buying people were
giving advice but his was more Pro debt
and psycho friendly and I guess he can
do his own thing if he wants to but he's
starting to give debt advice to people
and I'm not sure how to have like I want
to have a one-on-one conversation with
them yeah well just pull them aside and
just say listen you're confused this is
not your class okay and just say you
know you that's completely inappropriate
for you to come in here and contradict
everything that's going on if you want
to write your own curriculum teach your
own class and you need to go do that but
that but millions and millions of
millions of people have gone through
this class and we're not we have a flow
to the class and you know this is not a
debate it's a class and so you know
you're not here to debate if you want to
go through the class and learn you can
do that but you're not going to sit here
and contradict everything in the class
and talk it or I'm just going to have to
ask you to leave it's up to you I just
throw him out okay okay here's the part
here's the thing you're not going to
convince him that he's wrong okay
because if you do he'll have to quit his
job okay because he yeah you know he
thinks you know his job is based on his
wrong advice on things why do you get
into the insurance lesson he's going to
go into orbit oh I can't wait yeah so
you know that's what you've got there so
you know my grandmother you say those
convinced against their will or of the
same opinion still so I don't try to
talk him out of that I've got a really
good friend who owns a whole bunch of
car dealerships and he and I he does
try to talk me into leased car leasing
being a good idea and I don't try to
talk him out of leasing cars that is 9
or 10 car dealerships he's a multi
gazillionaire and we're friends and it's
okay we just that we just don't agree
about that and so I'm not going to talk
him out of it he's not gonna talk me out
of it so we can just not talk about that
and talk about something else right
right okay and that's you know that's
what this guy's got to do the problem of
this guy's not only does he have an
opinion but he's done any manners right
you don't come into somebody else's
house and so insult their cooking yeah I
got a little uh with it my blood started
boiling last night a little bit yeah
well I an appropriately so because and
you know what other people were too and
they're watching to see what you as the
leader of the group is going to do so
you know I'm not saying be unkind to him
a rude to him but he just you're gonna
have to establish some boundaries and
he's going to have to have some manners
or he's gonna have to leave okay
okay and if he needs his money by you're
not happy needs his money back just call
down here and tell him send his kit back
give him his money back it's okay okay
yeah cuz we've got financial peace so we
can give him his money back I thank you
so much for leading a class AJ and let
me tell you let me tell you this too let
me tell you you're going to have an
experience once you get this fly out of
the ointment you're going to have an
experience while watching people change
their lives right in front of you
because you volunteer to lead the class
so thank you for doing that
absolutely we love it thank you thanks
for calling it hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you are not a victim
you're not a victim of big corporations
you're not a victim of Wall Street
you're
victim of capitalism you're not a victim
of wealth inequality you're not a victim
of racism you're not a victim